hokel claims Republican crime concerns
our conspiracy Governor hulkel claimed
worries about crime ahead of midterm
election were a conspiracy and said her
opponent lizeldin and other Republican
critics were data deniers these are
Master manipulators they have their this
conspiracy going all across America
trying to convince people in the
Democratic states that they are not safe
uh well guess what they're also not only
election deniers they're also data
deniers safe places are the Democratic
State she said murders were down 14 in
New York City compared to last year but
all other major crimes were up including
33 Rising robberies and police
statistics show when you hear her say
stuff like this here's what I ask myself
because she said this on the show
yesterday
does the voter believe her and if yes
what percentage devoted that would vote
blue actually believes her saying that
what do you think the voters thinking
about so the voters don't believe her
because this is a you don't see what you
actually see liberal she's out there you
know she's a big government girl and
this has been her motto throughout by
the way for the last year and a half or
whatever it's been you don't see what's
actually happening you don't feel it
you're not really afraid to walk to the
grocery store and people are like no
actually I am so that's not going to be
a successful argument the problem in a
place like New York is that you have a
bunch of Voters and this happens in very
liberal cities oftentimes where they
will vote Democrat regardless you could
put Fidel Castro on the voting ball they
don't care it's like d oh he's back
that's oh yeah they won't care they will
they will to be outside yeah both sides
absolutely do that the problem is is
that when she's the problem you need
someone to what you need is a voter to
say this stuff's not working maybe I've
always been a lifelong Democrat maybe I
support the ideals of the party as they
once were this stuff is not for me
what's more important to me right now is
my Safety and Security and the Safety
and Security of my family end of story
and they have to call her Bluff so they
have to be willing to say sorry Kathy
and and by the way allow yourself to be
insulted by this because again this is
the left infantilizing you I talk about
this all the time by saying no no you're
a little baby you're a little baby and
you don't actually feel what you feel
you need to be able to respond as a
grown person I don't care liberal
Conservative Republican Democrat and say
no actually I do feel it I do feel it I
had to you know I'm afraid to go to walk
my kid to school every day and it's
because a lot of the policies coming out
of liberal DA's in New York City that
allow criminals to roam free so have a
response and feel okay with that even if
you are a lifelong Democrat and that
your commitment is to the party and the
cause something's gone wrong can she
lose
I think she can lose I I don't if I had
to guess I'd say she probably won't lose
but the fact that it's this close the
fact that it's this close in New York
state tells you what's going to happen
in other states around the country that
are not New York which are it's going to
be it's going to be a GOP sweep but Jed
let me ask you
um she she took over after Andrew Cuomo
was was given the the the left hook he's
out yeah so it's not like she had this
like sort of left hand
to be the governor she was sort of the
fill-in yep to replace him it wasn't
like there was this Groundswell of
people we love Kathy oakle and she got
elected she was replaced she got in
clearly things in New York have not done
well over the last few years so it's not
like there's this major base that she
has other than the traditional blue
Democrat liberal New York base so uh
anyway that I'm just pointing that out
it's not like she was elected she was
replaced
um
part number two is me at least at this
point in my life like it's very hard to
just trust what politicians say in
general left and right but especially
during election season during midterms
they're just gonna say whatever they got
to say to get elected whether it's true
whether it's not true I mean we're
living that in in midterms right now so
of course she's gonna say whatever she's
saying right now of course she's gonna
say don't believe Your Lying Eyes just
trust the trust the process here so
she's gonna do what she's got to do to
stay elected I think she will get
reelected again she's running for
governor in the one of the bluest states
in the country I think she was a couple
months ago she was up by like 20 points
I think it's narrowed to like six or
seven or eight that's still a quite
significant lead especially one week out
but we'll see we'll see if New Yorkers
are truly truly truly ready to make a
change or if they're just going to kind
of live the status quo that they've been
delivering they haven't sunk enough yet
New York City New York City in
particular which drags the whole state
down repeatedly every every year needs
to sink a little bit more for New
Yorkers to wake up and get a Giuliani
that came out of the David Dickens of
the world
um
she wasn't elected you're right but she
it has governed as a Democrat would
govern she's done nothing different from
any other standard you know hard left
Democrat in that position she's done
exactly what I would anticipate that any
Democrat would do
um and that's why yes you're right the
point you make about it's election
season right now they're going to say
whatever they need to say that's 100
valid which is why I always tell people
ignore everything that any politician
says in the couple of months before and
after like right around the election
time
um even after sometimes because then
it's a whole bunch of excuses as to why
they didn't do this look a year back at
what they actually did policy wise go
back a year when they weren't
campaigning when they weren't on the
campaign Stomp and look at what they
actually did policy wise what they were
look look back at what Kathy hokel was
saying about lockdowns remember those
beautiful pictures of Kathy that was
standing she was maskless standing in
front of a group of a whole bunch of
little kids with masks on look at what
she advocated when it came to the
lockdowns what was she saying about
mandatory experimental vaccines What
would she's saying about all these
things then you're going to know what
her position actually is because right
now she's desperate she's afraid you
think she's not looking and saying I'm
in New York state and Lee zeldin is
right on my tail come on what you're
basically saying is roll the tapes look
back a year ago 100 to see what people
say Yes um I haven't been following this
Dr Oz fetterman race he's close I know
sort of a national story because they're
it's like you take it no you take it you
take it nobody wants it no I don't think
Pennsylvania wants either them right but
if you look at fetterman and it seems
like he's not the healthiest guy he had
to get a stroke like less than six
months ago but his response one of the
clips I did see that were like you're
you're uh you've been against fracking
and he's like essentially like no I I
like Frack yeah crack me like right like
well a year ago you didn't you were
talking [ __ ] about fracking you said you
were anti-fracking he's like I Frack me
Frac that's basically that's actually a
pretty good summary of what was said too
people at home they're a lot that's
pretty close yeah so me like frackie
yeah and they they did it I I was about
to say that I saw his ad yesterday and I
was watching his ad and this is his ad
just so you know look at my eyes folks
here's his ad
in his reading
and just sitting there and he's just
reading reading reading and you can tell
it's just they're telling him what to
say and he's not saying it himself it's
not a True Believer if Oz loses it'll
tell you how much influence politics has
the fact that people just want to go
just one side because prior to us
running what did the world think about
us people love Roz they followed his
stuff they respected his stuff the
moment he said he's running God forbid
you run on that side now Oz is a bad
candidate like you said they're both bad
candidates you know some word that you
use Oz has never been seen as a guy that
had any issues until he ran against this
guy right now he's this horrible person
one problem with Oz is the the real Oz
is not a Pennsylvania Pittsburgh guy
like that's the whole not he's like he
just kind of like transplanted there and
he's like hey Pittsburgh Philly I'm with
you they're like yeah not so much Oz
didn't I have that one so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]